in three months you can three months i
haven't got three months outside
hi my name is fabio we are in my
restaurant vesuvio i started work pizza
chef when i was 14.
for six months i work free just for
learn this job tell me how to spin a
pizza then i started with plastic pizza
two three hour a day it was always dry
and it took me two three months with the
classic pizza after three months yes i
start with dough if you want i can show
you now yes let's do it this is our
dough yesterday the dough is light
because we do 24 hour fermentation
so show me without the pizza and the
mini time you put the pizza in the left
hand you already have to turn
when do you finish with left side with
right
it's not gonna happen
i think it's better you start with the
clothes right hand you put in the left
you start to turn oh one way just with
the end of the thing you make it look so
easy
after three months for you it will be
easy as well
this is the game
[Music]
[Music]
side you start from up to down great
take it inside you do the same like
before
okay now if you follow also
okay
push
mine is not going very well
in three months you can three months i
haven't got three months right like this
spin it's been put to the right left
right leg
spin straight away
there you go
oh
that's not bad
what's in the tomato sauce it's tomato
it's the italian one a little bit of
basil
we put this mozzarella we receive two
time a week from italy a touch of
parmesan cheese and after we put olive
oil from puja south of italy as well
this time we take the boot
and give a fire this is a proper
napolitan owen all the material is
coming from monopoly the floor of the
owen is stoned from a volcano i make the
best dough by cooking the electric oven
it changes the taste take the pizza like
caesar
here we go how long will i cook for now
the pizza is cooking 90 seconds 90
seconds wow
you check is a burn or not when cocoa
ready i take the peel and leave it down
it's not burnt the pizza
this is margarita it's a poppanopolitan
pizza come over there okay turn
go slowly now start to turn
[Music]
then for this side
it's okay it's not bad for kids not bad
for kids it's kid's sides yeah i think
it looks good i mean it's not as perfect
as round as yours but what do you think
for the first time is not bad just here
is a little bit more deep he is a little
bit more thin let me see how you cool
it's good maybe it's better than my one
let's go for this let's go for it
[Music]
ladies don't let this because everything
goes down this is the proper way to eat
it nipples we don't use knife and fork
that's revolutionized how i eat pizza
because it's keeping it hot and you can
feel the teaspoon of cheese the taste of
the basil you can feel the taste of the
parmesan it's so light and crispy it's
i've never eaten a pizza and thought
it's juicy maybe eat pizza banana pollen
pizza
i want to show you how we eat nipples
pizza portafonjo in english is a pizza
wallet
[Music]
wait in the street when you do shopping
we do everything
for you apollo
pizza apollo
perth
yeah it's okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you